[Music]
the cuomo's
[Music]
starring andrew and chris
[Music]
yes welcome back two brothers who love
to tussle
one's all hands the others all muscle
one's chasing girls
the other's doing curls one brother's
buff and the other should be in cuffs
one's on cnn the other should be in the
state pen
welcome to it's the cuomos they're like
kane and abel except one's a perv and
the other's on cable
tonight's episode after his montage of
kissing people got worse reviews in the
video of my colonoscopy
at sundance i didn't have any subtitles
new york governor andrew cuomo's remains
holed up in his mansion
figuring out how to save his career
that's according to the new york post
which is owned by our parent company
panda express there's been calls on both
sides of the aisle for cuomo to resign
following the ag's report that cuomo
sexually harassed 11 women
never mind the calls from children
wondering what happened to their
grandparents
meanwhile the new york times reports
that earlier this year cnn execs offered
chris cuomo a leave of absence
if he wanted to advise his brother on
his growing scandals
or turn chest and tricep days into a
full week
little workout joke chris said no
telling the network he'd continue his
show while obeying the rule that
prevented him from commenting on his
brother
well that's convenient chris didn't
address the report after it hit on
tuesday
but as pal don lemon did following this
totally normal handoff
our hearts and our thoughts have to go
out to the families
of these officers who took their own
lives i'm going to make my witness as
you say and you know
your witness i love you brother i love
you d lemon all right
this is don lemon tonight the calls are
getting louder and louder
this is what i'm talking about top
democrats from new york to the white
house
calling on governor andrew cuomo to
resign
[Laughter]
that is as awkward that's as awkward as
watching a movie with your parents and a
sex scene comes on
god i hated our home movies
[Laughter]
we're walking
[Laughter]
julie i haven't talked to you about this
we don't talk a lot
no actually during the week we need to
talk much more yeah call me
i won't okay do you think andrew will
step down
i call him andrew but he's the governor
uh no i do not i do not but i think
i you know he is a as a former
narcissist compulsive liar
i have experience on this so as a child
maybe high school college a little bit
of adulthood i used to lie a lot
you know about like minor things like i
got in a car accident when i was 16 i
told my dad i got run off the road
and hit a telephone pole the real story
is that i was showing off in front of my
friends and i
whipped into his driveway missed it
completely and rammed into the tree in
the front yard
he wanted to see the tree or the light
pole and of course that i got screwed i
shoplifted a couple of times i was very
young though and i got caught and
they're like how did this
how did this end up in your bag and i'm
like i didn't put it there somebody else
must have
but these are the kind of compulsive
lies that does not surprise me he is a
compulsive liar so
when you come forward and you say you
know deny deny deny
like when i cheated on my boyfriend once
when i was 17 years old and he was on
the phone while i was talking to the guy
i was cheating on him with
and i said that's what you get for
eavesdropping shame on you
so shame on you love gov because i know
i speak from experience i mean but
unfortunately he's gonna he's gonna drag
us through the mud
he did that i think what you're
describing should be called a cuomo
which is when they catch you in a lie
you turn it back on them and go always
disgusting i'm telling you i was a pro i
mean much
much long ago much longer yes all right
all right uh cap
what if he so if he doesn't step down
what does that do to this me too
movement
i think it's horrible because look the
me too movement this is a perfect
example of what it was supposed to fight
against as a guy in a powerful position
abusing this power to abuse people who
don't have power
and there's this investigation with 11
victims
corroborated but you know that he did
this
so if he faces no consequences that is
going to be really bad for any woman
who's ever in this situation now or in
the future
because if that's not enough then what
would ever be enough
because there's some aspects of the
metoo movement you talk about like aziz
i'm sorry we're just
out of control you know that stuff this
is this is what it was supposed to be
about and should be about why it's
important
so i certainly just get him he's got to
go he's he he had to go
there are seven invest investigations
into him at this point
go mm-hmm buck how does he govern
and i'm talking about chris cuomo chris
coyle yes
well bro cuomo as we call him he's
spending a lot of time making sure he
hits the macros properly but how do you
continue doing your job
when you can't even cover the news you
can't talk about the uh
i mean obviously you can talk about the
rest of the retirement homes or the
nursing homes
oh this guy's utterly shameless he
thinks he is the governor meaning he
always will be there's no one else who
could ever have the job he's not going
to step down he's going to force them to
try to pull him through
the impeachment process which will take
at least 60 maybe 90 days according to
people in new york state politics i know
by that point we'll be deeper into covid
maybe we'll all have the vaccine
passports and all the rest of it i mean
if you want a sense of the shamelessness
he had a smooch montage video that's
part of his defense he's like i kiss
i kiss ladies on the face on the head on
the foot on the shoulder the whole thing
and you were sitting there saying lee
there you go
he's just like everybody gets a smooch
plus biden sniffs ladies heads let's
remember so
he's he's hoping that people won't pay
much attention to the fact that he's a
weirdo but so
here's my but this is why i bring up
chris cuomo a lot is that
who comes up with montages people in tv
the montage is born from people like us
and producers
who say uh we need to show how stupid
this person is let's show a montage
that was from his that had to be from
his brother his brother had to say his
brother who was helping him with this by
the way as well as the
times up movement which there were some
of the people that are involved early on
in
trying i mean this is this is part of of
the game right you have to pay these
people to be your consultants
because then they're the ones that were
at the front forefront of the
weaponization of me too against certain
people
republicans right they always want to
use it when they want to use it as for
the movement overall
yeah i mean if you pay off the right
people now you'll get the uh the
expertise of the times up folks you know
what i'm talking about
the time's up crew they're all i wasn't
being consulted on whether this will
help cuomo
avoid me too but the time's up people
are meant to tell us
who should get in trouble for me too
yeah bad
it is bad and they all work amongst each
other yeah exactly and they work
they work they work for democrats they
don't work for republicans
to me this all goes back to 1996
monica lewinsky yes when feminist groups
decided to
side with bill clinton over monica
lewinsky and the democrats have never
learned their lesson and they continue
to pay the price over and over again
this is not like andrew cuomo was on a
zoom
uh and accidentally you know forgot the
camera was on and
like whatever happened like it's not
this is not tubin one of the things he
did was he changed the rules
so that the one gal that worked on the
state troopers that he had his eye on
so that she could actually come to work
for him and then he started to harass
her and
everybody around andrew cuomo knew it so
that chris cuomo
doesn't have to say anything about it
it's super convenient yeah exactly but
cnn's had a lot of
weird issues lately they have no ethics
to protect so that makes it a lot easier
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else